alors pauline marois qui était en
tournée aujourd'hui dans le
bas-saint-laurent et sans confirmer la
date de l'élection madame marois qui a
parlé de l'argumentaire qui sera utilisé
lors d'un déclenchement possible d'ici
une dizaine de jours
david gentilles et la première ministre
parle de blocage à la suite de la
présentation de son budget parce que je
vous le rappelle les libéraux et les
péquistes ont dit que s'ils avaient la
chance de se prononcer là dessus il
voterait contre le budget qui a été
présentée la semaine dernière donc
pauline marois parle de blocage complet
les termes sont lourds de sens patrice
et qui dit blocage dit qu'on puisse
chercher une issue et dans ce cas ci ce
serait à l'évidence le déclenchement
d'une élection sauf que pour l'instant
personne ne semble vouloir porter le
bonnet d'âne personne ne veut porter la
responsabilité quant au déclenchement
concret de cette élection et même le
gouvernement qui se prépare activement
et clairement depuis des semaines voire
des mois ne veut pas porter ce fardeau
là on écoute le tissu pauline marois ne
sommes pas une élection ce que je sache
alors elle se déclencheront si elle se
déclenche lorsque je le déciderai
puisque nous sommes un gouvernement
minoritaire et que j'ai compris que les
partis d'opposition ne voulait pas
adopter notre budget donc c'est un
blocage complet alors ils seront
responsables du fait qu on ait une
élection s'il y en a eu
alors on va ré entendre ces deux mots là
pardon assez souvent blocage complet
pour justifier donc les déclenchements
électorale et qui dit élection dit
préparatifs candidat vous avez appris
que certains libéraux dont yolande james
qui s'envole
yolande james en clair affirme que la
vie de maire parce qu'elle a un enfant
de 10 mois et est incompatible avec
celle de parlementaire la firme que sa
décision n'a rien à voir avec les
perspectives plutôt aux moyennes des
troupes de philippe couillard on écoute
la députée de nelligan
mais la petite enfance pense tellement
vite
ça passe tellement vite et cet enfant là
je l' ai voulu jeu contente d'avoir ma
famille et je veux être près d'eux et
patrice en plus aujourd'hui danielle
st-amand députée de trois-rivières a
confirmé qu'elle quittait tout comme
pierre marsan
[ __ ] et de robert baldwin un autre comté
une autre circonscription plutôt sur de
l'île de montréal comme celle de yolande
james la consolation pour les libéraux
c'est que ça fait deux comtés
intéressants qui peuvent être offerts à
des candidats vedettes on sait que les
libéraux en cherche actuellement mais
madame saint-amand à trois rivières ce
intéressant parce que ça c'est un côté
qui est relativement chaud elle était
très aimé dans ce comté la 27ème en
quittant c'est à compter que le pq va
vouloir la marge entre péquistes et
libéraux étaient très faibles à la
dernière élection
merci david au revoir en soirée